ultimately deductions what are some
common things that you think independent
creators forget to deduct that they
should
home office cell phone meals and travel
[Music]
welcome back to the think media podcast
today's episode is all about YouTube
taxes explained with money saving tips
for Content creators and this is kind of
a beginner's guide to YouTube taxes
however if you're even more advanced Our
Guest today is dropping some major
knowledge and wisdom to help you improve
your financial education and ultimately
make keep and invest more money back in
your business so you can make a greater
impact Now Matt Bontrager Our Guest is a
certified public accountant a CPA
licensed in Nevada and he's the managing
partner co-founder of true books which
is an accounting firm specializing in
real estate Matt strives to help clients
navigate complex tax code for their
benefit as well as keeping their
accounting records organized and up to
date Matt's also a content creator
himself and he's an in-demand speaker
for events masterminds and small groups
of Business Leaders and teams and the
reason I love Matt is even if you're not
into real estate one of the smartest
things you can do is start your creator
economy business grow it start
generating more revenue and eventually
invest intelligently in some of the best
assets that give you tax benefits and by
far real estate is the best and so this
is actually a three-part series that
Matt is joining us for in this first
part we're going to talk about some of
the foundations of you that you should
know as far as setting up a business an
LLC different things like that things
you should know as far as write-offs and
deductions and even just the mindset
that you should have when it comes to
learning something that a lot of us
don't want to talk about like I just
want to acknowledge you and say I
respect you for even clicking on an
episode like this there's a lot of you
know sexier topics like thumbnails or
titles or how do I go viral but you also
really want to make sure you're managing
your money properly you're staying in
compliance chance with the tax code but
you're also really taking advantage of
the ethical ways to save money on taxes
that content creators can take advantage
of as well as avoiding the pitfalls and
the mistakes and Matt covers all of that
so definitely also subscribe so you're
notified when we release part two and
three and today's episode is brought to
you by thinkcpas.com but we'll share a
little bit more about that with you
later so let's get into the featured
content
thank you
I'm here with Matt Bontrager and we're
talking about YouTube taxes explained
money saving tips for Content creators
and I'm honestly fired up because I
think this is going to be one of our
best episodes it's not the sexiest thing
like people don't necessarily get pumped
about structuring their businesses taxes
write-offs a lot of people have the
mentality of like the head in the sand
they just kind of like let me just avoid
that but I honestly believe this is one
of the most important skill sets to dive
into and so let's start it off though
Matt which is kind of the mindset some
people think this is complicated this is
overwhelming why should I even learn
this for a newer entrepreneur a newer
YouTube Creator somebody that's just
coming into making money a small
business owner why do they need to learn
this and what's like the right frame of
mind to get in
I think the the main reason is that
saying of the way you do anything is the
way you do everything and so it may seem
hard up front but if you spend an hour
two hours understanding what you need to
do correctly which we'll go over it's
really easy and it's going to set you up
for a ton of success going forward yeah
you know for me
um I I read a book years ago called Rich
Dad Poor Dad and it actually was one of
the most foundational things that would
that simply had this premise you need to
get a financial education that's like
Robert kiyosaki's biggest thing you need
to start understanding taxes
understanding how how are W-2s taxed
versus how are us a freelancer versus a
business owner versus an investor and
moving through these kind of cash flow
quadrants so what's the 30 000 foot
level though of why someone should start
a side business
and
why is YouTube technically a business
so first YouTube is technically a
business because you are self-employed
YouTube is paying you not as an employee
you are a subcontractor right you're
making affiliate income from using their
service
but the reason I would go back to why I
would start a business in today's
society in today's world is because if
you're a W-2 employee you get a paycheck
and that's it if you make 50 000 on
paper you're going to pay tax on fifty
thousand given a couple things you can
do to lower it or increase it but that's
it once you're self-employed you
literally have the entire tax code at
your disposal to try to bring it down to
zero so I would much rather be somebody
making 50 000 as a self-employed
contractor and pay zero in tax than to
be a manager at a department store
making fifty thousand and paying five to
ten thousand in tax what do you
technically need to do to become
self-employed
earn money by performing self-employed
services so you technically don't have
to start an entity to actually be
self-employed as soon as you start
collecting money which here in the U.S
would be like 1099 income self-employed
income from anywhere if YouTube pays you
some monetization you can start earning
some money but the key thing here is
someone might say oh well my YouTube
channel is not making any money yet I
haven't started a business is that true
no
so when you start the businesses in a
way it's when your mindset you you say
I've decided to start exactly even
without starting an entity that is one
of the biggest misconceptions is that
you need an LLC or an entity or a Corp
to take deductions and that is so far
from the truth
wow so and that that was an unlocked for
me years ago too that once I shifted
into this mindset I was like okay if I
start YouTube I can and I start
shooting photography for people I I pick
up a client I shoot a wedding video or
something I can now be in the mentality
of being a business owner before having
an LLC so when I'm doing that what I
learn from a tax perspective I could
just be a sole proprietor with just my
social security number true very true
and so then what are the benefits of
becoming an LLC or having a DBA or
proposed uh opposed to a sole proprietor
what's the difference legal protection
and that's where a lot of people get
caught up they think they need an LLC
for tax benefits not the case the only
reason you would really get an LLC is to
formally start a business and separate
the liability of you doing business from
your personal self what would you
personally say uh you know as a CPA and
of course you're not you're just giving
out general advice not specific advice
but what would you personally say
about when someone should start an LLC
if they're just kind of doing YouTube as
a side hustle as soon as I'm in the
pursuit of income
consistently I would start an LLC so if
I'm gonna go into YouTube and buy
equipment and put a plan together to
film I'm gonna set up an LLC at that
point are you also doing that for kind
of tracking because now there's an
entity and there's a spreadsheet
underneath that entity to say this
camera is all related to this LLC this
education I'm investing in is related to
this LLC exactly so as soon as I set
that up you have to treat it as a
separate entity and it's going to do all
of its own business as that business if
we stay on this topic for a second
um I'm curious what you think about this
advice that I was given we were going to
probably I was working at a church so I
had double a W-2 income I was making a
salary and I was I had side income
freelance clients would pay me so they
would pay me 10.99 contractor Services
essentially and then I was probably
getting 50 bucks a month from YouTube
and Amazon Affiliates is maybe giving me
32 bucks a month and so I did not have
an entity at this time I'm living in Las
Vegas I'm working at this chair church
and I asked these the tax preparers and
CPA we were working with at the time I
said do you think I should start an LLC
and they said do you think you're going
to get sued or do you think you have any
legal things and I said I don't I don't
think so I understand that protection
and they said I don't know if you should
do it until you're making six figures a
year what are your thoughts on that
I would disagree with that but what I
want to shine on that is notice how they
asked it was all in regards to liability
do you think you're going to get sued
and that just shows you the LLC is not
there to help you tax wise it's there to
help you liability wise but here's I
could be making 50 000 bucks again lower
than the number they told you and
potentially get sued I could make ten
thousand I can make no money and go out
and do business and really mess up and
get sued so that's where as soon as I'm
in the pursuit of income I'm just gonna
come out of the gate with the LLC
because what's the cost of an LLC here
in Nevada 425 bucks so it's an
investment yes and I know cash flow can
be tight when you're starting but again
if I have a plan in place to pursue
income with this business idea I'm going
to get an LLC
okay and so when it comes to setting an
LLC up what would you recommend people
have asked LegalZoom
um you know have somebody do it for you
do it yourself your thoughts to keep it
as simple as possible for the listener
if you are confident in doing it I would
do it yourself if not like a LegalZoom
because if you go to like an attorney or
some CPAs they're gonna charge you one
two thousand bucks and to me that's
overpriced I would much rather see you
use that cash to invest in your business
and Kickstart you I love it and I also
want to encourage if you're listening to
this we're going to talk about s Corps
in the second in part two of this
conversation where things get a little
more advanced but we kind of just want
to lay a foundation and that really
becomes interesting at around 45 50k a
year and so if you're net net that's
great so uh definitely listen to all
these and re-listen to these because I
know that we're dropping a lot of
information on you but just to recap a
couple things
so how much do you need to be earning
now we've started our LLC we intend to
make money how much do we actually need
to be earning for us to actually get tax
savings
how much would you need to earn to get
tax savings yeah what point does even
getting a write-off or a deduction even
become legitimate like is there a
certain number if I make under a certain
amount a year it's I'm going to have any
tax implications you don't need to earn
anything because let's be honest most
people when they start their businesses
they're going to buy equipment and
they're going to purchase things and
they're not going to make a lot of money
so it's very likely in year one you're
going to have more expenses than you do
income which is going to be a loss
so you're going to be so but how much
when do I start getting taxed how much
money uh or what am I taking that loss
against so if in the first year of doing
YouTube
um no money comes in what am I writing
off if I if I spend twenty thousand
dollars on camera building a studio
paint uh track lighting for my studio
right off the couch that's in the
background of my studio and we'll get
into deductions in a in a second I'm
kind of getting ahead of myself but what
am I actually writing off in that am I
able to write that off against my W-2
income yes and I was going to say that's
my favorite strategy for somebody that's
just starting a business because let's
say you are a department store manager
making 50k and you go out and start a
YouTube channel you buy some equipment
you buy a laptop you buy a mic you are
going to deduct some of those costs
against no income you likely won't make
anything your first year yes and now
what did we say up front if you make 50
Grand as a department store manager
you're going to pay tax on 50 Grand
let's say your business you lose three
grand because you paid for equipment to
start up now you can net that three
against your W-2 and now I made 47 000
on paper so now some of those taxes I
withheld on my paycheck what do I get a
bigger refund so this is the unlock and
this is why you need to start a business
this is why you might have technically
already started you needed to start
thinking different maybe set up an LLC
because you've got your day job and so
you're listening to this you make 40K a
year 60k a year 80k a year but that's
W-2 income so you start a YouTube
channel most listening you've already
started it you've bought a couple
hundred a couple thousand dollars a year
maybe you bought one of our programs or
one of our courses any books you buy
related to your your business so all of
that and then maybe your YouTube channel
is earning 5K 10K you could zero out the
income of your YouTube channel or your
online business but you're also able to
take losses against your W to income the
question people are going to ask though
how long can you do this the IRS us
might identify this eventually as a
hobby but the genius is you have a
little bit of time to do this at least
for a while and it's also Fair because
most businesses aren't profitable for a
couple years exactly but there is a
certain point in time when you do need
to show profit what is that time frame
year three is ideally when you want to
turn a profit and exactly as you said
the reason could be if you consistently
show losses on paper and I'm the IRS I'm
going to think are you really here to
make money or just accumulate losses and
make no income and is it really a hobby
and if they try to say it's a hobby then
all of those deductions could be
disallowed and so and again this ties
back into what you were saying being
organized and keeping your books is
going to help you show that you're a
solidified business so the secret here
is if you were just like I just love
photography and I love drones and I've
decided to follow this advice you'd be
misunderstanding us if you just for the
next 10 years thought I got this cool
job and I just want more tax deduction
so I'm going to write off all these
expensive lenses and cameras and drums
phones and travel to go films but the
goal is you're saying you could go 24
months you could travel around because
you're filming Drone footage for your
YouTube channel you're investing in
drones you're investing in cameras and
then you also have a plan which I hope
if you're listening to the think media
podcast you have a plan to actually be
profitable that you could it could be
two whole years of losses but in that
third year now ad census kicking in
you're selling your Luts you've got an
online course your services whatever
else so just like any other business
certain business like Amazon they
actually probably a little bit different
because they're bigger than the IRS but
they were they weren't showing profit
for years for sure but in this case
you're saying you're gonna be safe if at
least by year three you want to start
showing profit yes and that doesn't mean
that if you truly lost money in year
three four five that you can't still
take the loss I would recommend you as a
CPA to still do that but again you want
to be conscious of is your Revenue go
showing up because maybe the auditor
comes and they go hey you've taken a
loss now four years in a row but in year
three you made 20 grand Top Line and in
year four you made 40 Grand so you're
showing some sort of pursuit of income
but again it would be you want to turn a
profit eventually unless you're
reinvesting in the business and showing
losses that makes sense if you're just
kind of joking around you're like I'm
writing off my PS5 and my games because
I'm a streamer and and then you just are
never show anything but if you're
actually like continuing to level up
your office and all this kind of stuff
and your streaming income is going up
and up and there's brand deal
transactions so that kind of goes back
to one of your big pieces of advice
which is record keeping why is the
biggest and people hate that oh they
hate it but why is that so important
because at the end of the day it's going
to save you money with your accountant
I'll be honest if somebody comes to us
now and they have clean records and one
of them has messy records the person
with Messy records is going to get a
higher Bill why because we have to spend
more time on their work and two tax
planning which is a little bit more in
episode two
that that's where the money's made
that's where you're going to sit down
and strategize on how to bring your
income to zero on paper right and help
you make money and pay zero in tax you
can't do any of that unless you have
your books ready and what do I mean by
books ready for those of you listening
could you come to me on Monday this is
what I always like to ask and sit down
with me to tax plan but could you show
me a year-to-date profit and loss could
you show me what your expenses were most
of the time that answers no
so let's if you're listening to this
first of all that's painful but second
of all you go I want the one two three
steps of what to do next uh of course
you know this episode is brought to you
by
thinkcpas.com that's just a a your
ability to work with Matt mats who we
work with
um and if you're at a certain level
we'll talk about that later he'd be a
great one to connect with but we also
want you to just be able to potentially
run this independently if someone's
trying to kind of do this on their own
and they want to prepare for this is
there a software you recommend get this
software and start plugging numbers into
this QuickBooks Online you can sync your
bank account directly to it and it will
feed the transactions in it's as simple
as you bought a meal drop down menu
meals got paid for a Netflix
subscription for your office for your
clients subscriptions it's that easy
what do you think about like things like
mileage you like apps or anything for my
like you my like you and so if there's
business related you could swipe left or
right so now you could so you're
tracking you're tracking your mileage
you're entering things into QuickBook
QuickBooks what do you think about
things like throwing it out there like
bench accounting so some of these like
online services that may not be as high
level as having a dedicated person like
you uh but having kind of a hybrid model
have you heard of those yeah no yeah
they're great and that's where the
differentiating factor is are you
somebody that wants to have no in like
little to no involvement go bench if
you're somebody that's okay I'm really
tight on cash flow I don't want to spend
200 bucks a month with bench I'd rather
save the money and do it myself because
there's not a lot of activity go
QuickBooks and do it yourself got it so
DIY QuickBooks do it yourself you could
look at bench one of my things you go to
Google and type in bench versus because
there's other services and you could
compare and contrast and then you get to
a higher level you want more help with
like Consulting and you're in tax
planning Tax Services or rather
projections and we'll talk more about
that in episode two but but
summarizing we're talking about get your
numbers right commit to QuickBooks
online because by the way we use
QuickBooks as well so at whatever level
Sonia who is our CFO my wife
um she keeps detailed records
um and and then that is easy for you to
now come in and look and obviously it
saves us a lot of time and energy and so
it's painful you may not want to do it
but you got to do it or marry the right
person uh or you know connect with the
right person or or collaborate with the
right person because it's absolutely key
to be on top of your numbers that was
how we were able to tax plan is because
she has it ready you're not wasting time
going back and saying hey yeah I have my
receipts but I don't know exactly what
I've lost or made and then it's like
well I can't really help you yeah and
there is it is another model I've heard
was uh my Fred Chad
um he he was much more in person
everything's online now but he's much
more in-person transactions what he
would do is he would throw all of his
receipts in a shoe box and he would hand
that over to someone and he didn't care
he was a a like a Judd and black serve
uh salesman so he's he was making good
money he didn't care but that that would
be the other thing is you're getting
make sure you get those receipts they're
emailing them to you right you get the
receipts and the email you use to sign
up for almost everything online maybe
you got to collect all of your receipts
and that's also where you can also get
some of your biggest savings let's talk
about deductions so the big the funny
thing is there's that Meme right is
there's that Meme of like it's a
write-off it's a deduction what does
that mean it means it was free it means
I didn't it was I you know I bought a
camera my camera was free well that is a
myth right let's just talk about why
deductions how much are people really
paying in taxes and how much how much
are taxes actually costing people when I
think people think their biggest
expenses they think it's their internet
bill is their biggest expense their
coffee bills are basic expense their
mortgage bill is their biggest expense
how much are people actually paying
attention taxes let's think about it
this way if you're at the 25 tax rate
between whatever state you live in and
federal every dollar you miss because of
bad record keeping you're paying 25
cents in tax
so that's why it's so important to keep
track of your expenses and your
deductions so I would say 25 to 50
percent in overpayment of tax because of
bad tracking
which is absolutely massive so so let's
a lot of people are probably not making
six figures a year but let's let's just
round it because it's easiest math for
me you make a hundred thousand dollars a
year at 25 percent you're gonna pay
twenty five thousand dollars to the IRS
that's assuming your income is net a
hundred thousand dollars so
theoretically then with proper
deductions and tax strategy you could
pay instead of 25 you could pay 20
instead of 20 and theoretically you
could pay zero especially I'd say on
average they should be falling 10 to 15.
so you that'd be fifteen thousand
dollars back in your pocket that's in
your business and back into your
business reinvest so you're talking
about
if you make a hundred thousand dollars a
year you're probably paying the IRS 25
000 when you should only be paying them
like 15 and you're keeping the other 10.
or reinvesting it Etc and you have more
to show for it after now you have that
next office you want to upgrade to that
next vehicle you want to upgrade to for
your business whatever else okay so then
ultimately deductions what are some
common things that you think independent
creators forget to deduct that they
should
home office cell phone meals and travel
those are some sleepers that really okay
let's hit them so home office so what
can you do to write off your home office
how does it work so honestly your CPA
should give you a template to really
track this which again we can give to
you and then you can send to the
listeners but for example if you work
out of your home
your power bill now has become partially
deductible your internet bill your cable
bill the equipment that we're using so
if you I know in my office I have a desk
I have a chair I have cameras monitors
all of that can be deductible so keeping
track of all of that
is really important and so and you do
that based on square footage exactly so
for things like your cable bill yeah
your office let's just say is 10 of the
square footage of your entire home yeah
which is square foot of your office
divided into square foot of the entire
home yep you get 10 all of these General
utility bills of your entire house could
ideally be allocated 10 towards your
business so uh some specific advice here
we're here in Anderson Studios that's
where we film The think media podcast
and he actually has devoted an entire
Loft
an entire office an entire closet and an
entire bathroom because and and for the
IRS too to know there's other bathrooms
there's a whole downstairs there's whole
so this is entirely devoted to business
he's also able to list this out sublease
it to us or whatever and others and he
has he's able to use this space so it's
entirely devoted to business it's also
then quite a bit of square footage yes
this is at least five to seven hundred
square feet four to seven hundred square
feet in what I'm seeing here yeah so it
so it's so then let's just say it was 20
of the entire house because it's much
bigger and then he's got a lot to show
for it videos to show bigger than a
normal home office production is
happening here so would you then say
your electric bill you're gonna you're
gonna write off twenty percent of your
luxury Bill the percent that is the
square footage of the office exactly and
then that apply you could apply that to
water and everything mortgage interest
if he rented this place instead of
owning it not sure which one but even if
you rent the property yeah now portion
of rent is deductible and if you you
don't rent it but you have a mortgage
you can write a percentage of mortgage
interest off exactly because your
principal is not enough sheesh okay so
home office is is gnarly and stick with
us I know this episode's already kind of
crazy but that's a big one you also said
cell phone you're gonna write off 100 of
your cell phone the majority of it right
so like that's where you start to get
into why would you track miles why do
you track allocations is because some
things that you purchase in life and
that's one of the best things about
being self-employed you mix business and
pleasure so I'm going to use my cell
phone for business and I'm going to use
it for personal use so if I think that
I'm using my cell phone because I'm
mainly on it 70 80 90 of the time for
business or I have a separate cell phone
just for business then I'm writing that
entire thing off but yeah I'm definitely
going to take a portion of my cell phone
percentages was one of the biggest
secrets that I learned that changed
everything for me because I kind of
thought it was this all or nothing
that's why they're sleepers because
people think they're all or nothing yeah
I can't use it I use my car I went to
the grocery store and like it's not a
hundred percent business but percentage
is and what does the IRS asking is it
what reasonable ordinary ordinary and
necessary is it ordinary that someone
else in this business would spend money
on this and is it necessary for me to
pursue my income which doing deals
talking to clients on a cell phone is
very reasonable and having a car is
ordinary and necessary but then the key
and this is the advice I was given your
goal would be in keeping record keeping
in and doing record keeping working with
a great CPA or at least really
understanding this stuff is then
thinking about if you were to present
this in a hearing
and someone asked you why did you write
off 80 of your car and you go well like
here's actually here's the the tracking
of it here's when I use it and I barely
use it for personal but I predominantly
use it for work and they go oh that's
reasonable or why did you write off a
certain percentage of X is that the
right thinking exactly I've been in
audits with an IRS auditor sitting just
like this and that's exactly the
discussion you have and there's just
another person saying why is this
reasonable and and then you and then
your thing is to justify and back it up
so similarly uh if you were to write off
travel do in some cases you might not
write off a hundred percent of travel
exactly and and and would you say that
in an audit is uh auditing situation or
in defending yourself to IRS that it
probably looks even better because it's
thoughtful that you are doing
percentages if you go Madam writing off
the whole trip exactly but you go no no
like so it's listen I needed to visit
this rental property I have or I went
and filmed I went filmed a podcast with
somebody here's the record of the
podcast and I shot a video but I was
there for two weeks did you really need
to be there for two weeks exactly so you
might write off a portion of your travel
now the IRS also sees you're taking it
really seriously to be thoughtful and uh
so percentages is that unlock big okay
so home office smartphone what was the
other one meals that's because now it's
a hundred percent that just shocked the
entire tax Community when that came out
so how do I write off meals what would
be a legitimate meal that I could write
off me and you going to dinner to
discuss working together what about me
uh getting coffee on the way over here
for this work day pers if you brought
coffee to us yes if you bought coffee
for yourself technically no okay so see
the difference you got to be doing
something with a colleague or an
employee or a prospect got it so if I
take the think media team out
um or a team member to have a leadership
conversation to to talk about things a
higher I take you out as a client or
somebody we're collaborating with I
could write that off 100 right now my
favorite thing to do and that changed
recently it used to be 50. so somebody
would come to us with 10 000 in meal
expense they would only get five but
because of kovid and the restaurant
industry getting hit so hard to stick
this is an exact example of how the
government stimulates spending through
tax code they're like hey restaurants
are getting crushed we want you to spend
money in the restaurant industry we're
going to give you a hundred percent
deduction what do you know people are
spending money like crazy now on dinners
and going out because it's fully Tech
right it's fully tax deductible so I'm
glad you brought that up because a
listener could also be wondering like
wait a minute here are you trying to
game the system is this some kind of a
trick are you trying to I know about you
business people trying to use the tax
code you just said it the reason these
things are here is actually to stimulate
the economy because money it it went to
100 especially during the pandemic
because they wanted to get business
owners giving restaurants money because
they want business owners to give car
dealerships money because they want
business owners to give Canon vid IQ and
Canon money they want business owners to
give other business owners for
Consulting and services and courses
because it all stimulates the economy
monies make the gears turn look at PPP
Lots right so that this is actually how
when you invest money not in uh of
course personal expenses but when you
invest in business expenses I heard some
advice from I think it was Grant Cardone
he had like rules that he liked to go
through before making a purchase and one
of his big questions he'd ask is can I
write it off he hesitates to buy it but
it's like if I can write it off then
it's a whole different deal because I'm
potentially going to pay 25 less for
that 37 percent less than that and not
only that which are also then investing
in is not in just like
buying a camera so it sits there you're
investing in a tool that will give you
the ability to create better content the
next year so if you can consistently
kick the tax can down the road that's
why at your end we're trying to buy new
laptops helps us go faster gets that new
Macbook M1 helps us edit faster be more
productive hopefully also increase the
satisfaction of the team saves me money
because I'm paying them the same
regardless but now they're more
productive in the time because their
laptop's going faster but we also get a
major discount on that in our case 37
percent off of that laptop we have more
buying power and our assets are
technically bigger although Tech is
becoming more and more useless over the
years but it's nice we have a bigger
world bigger impact all because of
thinking through this so you talked
about home
uh home office you talked about meals
you talked about phone what were the
other ones travel
so you can write off travel so are you
telling me if I'm gonna go to think
media's conference in Las Vegas that I
could write that trip trip yes so how's
that work so the thing you want to keep
in mind with travel is a 5149 rule okay
if I'm going for four days I want three
of it to be for business that allows me
to write off the transportation too okay
so you can see and you hear people say
wrap the weekend meaning let's go on a
Thursday we'll work Thursday Friday
we're gonna play Saturday Sunday and
we're going to work Monday that entire
trip is deductible now for my travel
cost to get there so 51.49 just being a
quick rule of thumb of how many days am
I going to spend here and is the
majority of it going to be business if
so yes on writing off your travel so if
I buy a ticket to think media's
conference in Las Vegas I could write
the ticket off I'm going to write the
airline off I'm gonna write the hotel
off I'm gonna write meals off while I'm
there it's a business trip I'm gonna
write my Uber off to get there I'm gonna
write out the Uber off and then of
course if I buy some souvenirs or
whatever that's personal
um but yeah if I buy a cool think
notebook that I'm going to use to keep
my business notes in if I if I buy think
media merch that's related to okay yeah
um and so uh travel and is there any
others common deductions Indie creators
forget to deduct
um
I think just equipment in general like
people buy cords cameras all of these
small accessories and they just forget
and it's again through the leakage of
bad bookkeeping but
think of it now just like Grant says
every time you purchase something can
this be deductible yes yeah is there a
limit so a question came in from Joe he
said would you consider two iPad person
purchases two laptops or one laptop with
a desktop all in the same year excessive
uh for a single member LLC not at all
and so who's it to say that it's
excessive
I would honestly say your accountant is
going to help you navigate that road
because here's an example
if I see a tax return where somebody
made 25 000 in revenue and their meals
say 22 000 that seems odd got it red
flag so kind of reasonable what would a
reasonable human look what would not
what would cause a red flag yes but then
it right and so something like that a
variant so here's honestly how the IRS
is going to catch you every tax return
has a business code so if you're a small
business taxpayer you're going to report
your business on Schedule C but anyways
you have a small business code there and
what it is is on their back end system
if out of all the tax returns with that
business code your meals is 200 percent
higher there's likely a chance you'll
get flagged and that's how they track
this and that's right and that's the
purpose of that and that's where your
accountant would see business code and
they'd be able to help you navigate
those roads but that's where at the end
of the day if that person had 25 000 of
income and 22 000 in meals and it was
legitimate we're gonna do it but it
would just be very unlikely amazing okay
so kind of just to hammer in this point
and really learn through this a great
question came in from Alaska Homestead
on our community Tab and uh the question
was
like so your cooking channel let's say
and you buy a new smoker but you're
going to use the smoker in videos but
you're also going to use it for personal
use is this deductible and if so uh what
percentage would you recommend in that
situation so something like that is
obviously going to come to allocation
but if I'm a big enough Channel and I
know this is where it gets great but if
I'm a big enough Channel and I know that
nine out of 10 times I'm using that that
smoker for my channel I'm writing the
entire thing off because that doesn't
mean that if I have a company car and I
write off the entire thing that I can't
go pick up groceries in it yeah you know
what I mean so that's where it is a gut
feeling and that's where advisory
Services really come in you want
somebody in your corner to ask this to
but I would write off the entire thing
that also gives you a perspective on
like you're holistic because truth be
told like we're we're a multi-million
dollar business so so maybe one
particular piece of tech is like a
rounding error like one particular yes
like extension cords or or even even
more expensive Tech you buy that another
way to put it would be here in CES in
Vegas
they set up all these booths all these
companies come in they spend thousands
on building a booth with Ikea furniture
and then they throw it away after yes
which is awful but it speaks to the side
where like where did that go I mean if
if Lisa took the furniture home they're
like it's being thrown away regardless
and at that scale so your point exactly
is that's why advisory services are
important because
um at a certain scale like you're barely
no money's coming in it's more of a
hobby level and and you're trying to
write off your smoker and your dishes
and whatever but if you were like an at
scale Cooking Channel you might have a
level of volume of stuff coming through
where you literally use it once in a
video and that's legitimate for the
whole scale of how much money that that
video uh generates and of course you
know you're the expert but am I thinking
right that was the best answer because I
was just gonna say for that channel it
may be a smoker for think media it may
be an exotic car or a small plane sure
yeah you know so that's that's exactly
like you were saying right like at scale
exactly totally because of the level of
the content you're doing yes and
actually that speaks to again and this
channel is at 34 000 subscribers that's
a bit they're getting to a level where
it would probably be smart to work with
think right off that smoker yes yeah and
to be working with somebody like
thinkcas.com because you want wisdom
with that and again that's just a form
to work with Matt and his team but uh
okay so what are the tax rates so now
thinking about this and and again this
information is obviously we're talking
here in the US you got to look at your
local you know area but it's it's a
bracket system what does that mean so a
lot of people get confused where they
think oh I met this bracket which is
let's say 24 I'm gonna pay 24 on all of
my money and that's not how it works so
if you want to pop up what the brackets
are here the way that the bracket system
works is you're gonna pay x amount of
dollars or you're gonna pay x amount of
tax on so many dollars and then when you
move to the next bracket you're only
going to pay that new rate on those
amount of dollars and those amount of
dollars so you consistently move up like
for example the top tax rate thirty
seven percent you're only going to pay
that on over like on money over let's
say 530 000 or 470 000 whatever income
yes no so if so if if you make 500 or
whatever a thousand and then you make
another 500 000 you're only going to pay
37 on the on the past exactly past that
number yes and that's where you bring up
a good topic too which is on net income
so for example if my business made a
hundred bucks before expenses I'm not
going to pay tax on a hundred bucks I
first get to take my expenses against it
and let's say it brings me down to 80.
I'm gonna pay tax on 80. yeah so that's
what a deduction is it just lowers the
amount of money subject to tax yes okay
and and again highly recommend you
subscribe to the podcast on YouTube or
audio wherever you're listening in
episode two it gets it is probably one
of the most important things that
business owners that are starting to
scale should be thinking about what are
some more advanced level kind of
write-offs or intelligent ways I should
be thinking especially related to let's
say real estate or investing in or
retirement Define benefit plans all this
kind of stuff that's all episode two
um let's break down some uh mistakes
we've already hit them but just recap me
to to simplify biggest mistakes people
are making they're listening to this and
and what are what are some of the
biggest mistakes that a new Creator a
new small business owner and everyone
listening to this should be thinking
like a business now uh that they make
the number one if you met with me next
week could you show me a profit and loss
year to date and if that answer is no
you need to get that going which I would
recommend QuickBooks okay so keeping
your your expenses organized which
includes tracking of receipts yep so
saving receipts and is there any other
than shoebox especially things being
digital what is your way of tracking
receipts receipts plus QuickBooks so
QuickBooks actually has a oh you just
had this transaction do you want to take
a picture of the receipt and tie it to
it yes right from your phone got it yeah
I still actually have a lot of receipts
printed out I am I'm so blessed to have
Sonia in my life but I will say they say
do you want a receipt I'll say yes I use
a pen and I write what's on there for
all the meals I write on the receipt did
I write you know met with Kyle talked
about social media and uh and then and
then these days though how about this
how about a business credit card
because some if it's devoted a credit
card or debit card uh because then
everything you put on that if you swipe
it it's for business what do you think
about that yes and so that's where I
always tell people try and get a
separate business credit card if you can
actually under your business so if you
have an LLC yeah get a business credit
card for the LLC but then the next
question is well it's a personal credit
card but I like the reward points sure
but only use it for business then
because at the end of the year you don't
want to go through a thousand
transactions and see what's business and
what's personal so what about separate
bank accounts huge huge because so you
don't want to pierce the corporate veil
and that's where this can come up let's
say you get sued yeah and then the
attorney looks into the records and they
see you were using your business bank
account as like a personal piggy bank
you're going to Spa with it are you
really using this business as a business
and if that answer is no then that liab
all that liability protection is gone so
other than tracking for accounting and
keeping things separate to keep you sane
in your account insane for liability
purposes which was the whole reason you
got the LLC yes keep it separate okay so
to summarize you want to keep great
records and one of the ways to keep
great records is is to make sure you
don't pierce the corporate veil to keep
it simple if you want to use a debit
card or um and your Dave Ramsey fan and
you don't believe in credit cards then
just have you have your personal debit
card and you can have a business debit
card if you're a think media fan and
you're self-disciplined you love credit
cards and you always pay off the balance
in full but you understand at the scale
we we get something like three thirty
thousand dollars in points back every
year for cash back and I've heard you
know Dave's like you know ain't nobody
ever got rich you know by credit card
points and I'll be like well that might
be true but I'll tell you this thirty
thousand dollars is like a real amount
of money and with a level of business
expenses that we spend uh we just funnel
those through a credit card the key
though you're saying is even if you
should set up an LLC you said that but
even if you didn't just make sure to
have one clearly that it's all organized
all in one place you can see all of the
those business expenses were on One
credit card because you love the points
and then something else on your other
one that's personal and keep those
separate what happens if you
accidentally make a mistake it's first
of all not the end of the world second
it's still deductible yeah so if you end
up using a personal card for business
don't think you don't get the right
option you still get the write-off and
three try not to do it again yeah it
happens great okay and so as we land the
plane
um
foundational tips that we promise to for
YouTubers starting a business for
Content creators starting a business let
me know if I miss anything you you
recommend set up an LLC I do as soon as
you intend to make money and you're
taking this serious which if you're
listening to this podcast that's you
it's like Jay-Z said I'm not a
businessman I am a business comma man
I'm a business so even if I'm just
starting my YouTube channel my camera
all this different stuff I need to start
taking a record it's also kind of like
like you should start acting like it
before you're fully it
if you're single and you want to get
married you shouldn't just think oh
someday I'll just all of a sudden be
ready for marriage you should start
walking the walk and so walking the walk
means entering your numbers tracking
receipts spending until it also means
investing yourself if you're a business
owner that wants to grow you're a
business owner that's investing in your
business so you're tracking your travel
you're tracking your cameras you're
tracking your gear you're tracking your
education great so set up an ilc get
QuickBooks start entering your numbers
maybe get get your separate bank
accounts uh get get a card for business
and a card for personal
um debit if you want credit if you want
travel miles if you want
um and anything else to just have a
solid foundation once you've done all of
that the next step would honestly be to
find somebody to do your taxes and so H
R Block
not bad but I'm always a fan of because
I get this question all the time when
should I hire a CPA yeah and I honestly
think the second you become
self-employed okay because all the
questions that anyone's gonna have
watching this who they gonna ask yeah
exactly the video answers it but and and
again listen if I I highly recommend
we've been working with Matt now for a
while and and you have that option but I
just know this list and I know a lot of
listeners might have run into the same
thing we did get a CPA back when we
started Clear Vision media 2009 my wife
and I are living in Marysville
Washington and I started to study I'm
reading Rich Dad Poor Dad I'm studying
the books I'm I'm studying online and I
just remember I would go down to our CPA
and I was the one with the ideas I was
the one who was asking questions and
what he would do is I'd bring up
something intelligent like hey this is
kind of what we're doing for a business
can we write this off and you'd be like
well I guess like that is accurate and I
was like bro you got the wrong energy
yeah I was like I'm looking for yeah I'm
looking for you to bring me the ideas
like why am I coming with all the
creative ideas and bringing things up so
you do want to it's a big deal and and
the key is this if it's you talk the six
figure number right you could probably
pay 25 000 in taxes just really rough
numbers in the savings alone not only
will that pay for the expenses of of the
CPA but and then some it'll pay for mile
mile IQ which I resisted that one too I
was like my IQ 67 bucks a year or
something like that and and the savings
will pay like that's I think the mindset
scared money don't make money no very
true so you want you're investing in
your business but it's also a smart
investment because the return you're
going to get is you're gonna save even
more than the cost of keeping it right
having a good CPA having a good advisory
right you should always see a return on
all of the costs we've just talked about
especially your CPA they should be they
should be a profit Center for your
business and yeah and if you're worth
the wrong person and the problem with an
H R Block or my CPA in Marysville
Washington is they weren't the kind of
return people they still charged me too
actually too but like they I they
weren't bringing the ideas and they
weren't really ready for the crater
economy that too that's I think it's
it's a whole new kind of world so you
want someone on The Cutting Edge and
again one of the reasons why we like
working with you we met you through Ryan
Pineda is Ryan was not just investing in
doing real estate but he was also doing
content you guys are obsessed with being
on the bleeding edge you're helping us
stay sharp because it's a new world it's
a new way of con new world of content
creation traveling for creating content
all these different things so you want
an advisory that's tuned into what's
happening now that's not thinking like
10 15 years ago exactly somebody that's
helping clients similar to you in their
situation you know and I mean the CPA
industry is a lot of old heads they're
not really in tune with what's going on
so exactly like you said you want to be
up to date with what's going on and you
want somebody to that's in your corner
that like they're gonna ask the
questions and poke around and because
that's what we get all the time is you
know I went to my old CPA and they were
like exactly like you said yeah you
could do this or I haven't heard of that
I'm not comfortable doing that and
that's a sign that you maybe need to
find something that you maybe need to
sign find somebody else great advice
okay Matt you you're posting a lot of
great content on social media people
want to follow you where are you at
Instagram's the best at Matt Bontrager
so definitely follow Matt you can check
out the show notes and then also if you
want to connect with Matt and true books
his company if you go to
thinkcpas.com they uh just have a form
to see if that's even a right fit for
you but we'll also hook you up with a
special deal just because uh you met
them through us
um if not cool get your books in order
figure it out get it set up right and
all of those details are linked up in
the show notes and so definitely connect
with Matt and his team and make sure
you're subscribed because it's about the
rabbit hole is about to go deeper with
some more advanced strategies in episode
two
[Music]
so if your brain hurts after listening
to this first episode with Matt I don't
blame you there's a lot of information
here and I want to encourage you pace
yourself you may want to listen to this
episode again because it's it's heavy
like there's just a ton of new terms and
terminologies to learn and I feel like
the tax code is kind of overly complex
like they're trying to trick us who
knows but nevertheless it's one of the
biggest things you can invest in one of
the most important things you can invest
in is getting your financial education
is learning uh is increasing your
financial intelligence and that's what
this series is all about and I just want
to ask if you got value today would you
consider sharing this with somebody
maybe there's a business owner a content
creator maybe there were some aha
moments where you're like man I didn't
know that or I hadn't thought about that
one of the best ways that we can
accomplish our mission here at think
media is by getting this information in
the hands of as many people as possible
we want people to not pay we just want
people to pay their fair share of taxes
but my not more than they should be
paying and we also want people to
understand the benefits of some of the
write-offs and deductions that you can
take that the tax code incentivizes
because it means you're scaling your
business you're investing in tools and
resources and real estate and people and
you're ultimately making a greater
impact and creating a win-win-win-win
scenario you're making more you're
helping other people make more and feed
their families it's actually really why
I believe it's it's the pro side the
positive side of the tax code is they
want to incentivize business owners
value creators you're a small business
owner as a content creator and you want
to be maximizing those benefits and so
make sure you're subscribed for part two
and also share this out with anybody in
your network that would maybe benefit
from this that would mean the world to
us also if you are listening on audio it
would mean the world to me if you left a
review over on Apple podcast and if
you're here on YouTube I would love any
follow-up questions because we want to
have Matt back on the show so drop a
question in the comments section down
below so that we can continue to help in
whatever way possible your tax related
business related business structure
related questions and then finally if
you're a business owner that would like
some help specifically from Matt Mattis
who we use we use true books it's been a
great experience we've actually switched
a couple different times that we've now
been with Matt for a few years if you
check out the show notes or just go to
thinkcpas.com you'll be able to fill out
a form and you'll see if working with
them is right for you if I would say if
you're at a level where money is coming
in you have some momentum in your online
business or in your YouTube channel and
the kind of income streams that are
coming in it's time to get your books
right and it's time to get your CPA
right Matt and I might not be the right
fit but somebody is one of the best
investments you can make is ultimately
in getting a good Financial team around
you and I do recommend true books so you
could check them out at think
cpas.com that's
thinkcps.com and uh I will see you in
the next episode of the think media
podcast